let's pull up this story from town hall
from march 9th my birthday just past
week russia funneled oh thank you russia
funneled cash to anti-fossil fuel
climate extremists 2018 report
they say as the cost of a gallon of gas
continues to break state and national
records many are criticizing president
uh biden for taking an energy
independent united states and putting
the country in the position of relying
upon foreign powers to meet american
consumers demand in addition to the pain
being felt by americans at the pump it's
also become clear that being energy
dependent is a national security
liability when foes around the world
just russia china iran at all get antsy
or start an all-out war conservatives
rightly point to radical
environmentalists unhinged anti-fracking
and anti-pipeline activists and democrat
officials including biden schumer pelosi
sanders and aoc as the driving force
behind anti-fossil fuel protests they go
on to say just a few years ago through a
congressional investigation into russian
interference in u.s politics revealed
evidence that russia had a role going
back more than a decade now in the
radical campaign to get the u.s and
other western countries to shift away
from fossil fuels a goal much like one
of biden's energy secretary jennifer
granholm stated last week now the first
thing i want to say is i'm very
skeptical skeptical when it comes to the
russian collusion the the russia
influence and stuff but that's
it
it's fair to say
we know that russia china iran north
korea even smaller countries are
constantly playing these propagandistic
moves my question is as we're learning
about this
is it actually that severe is is russia
actually having an impact in the united
states to the point where it's going to
cause us to
become energy dependent or is it
marginal well i'm not sure what effect
russia is having on it but it is very
telling which side of this issue they're
on
because they're not exactly interested
in it they want us
they want us to buy their oil
so when it was russia russia russia with
trump right what was the incentive for
not for wanting him in there right there
was no incentive for them to
want trump to be the next president that
made no sense right it made no sense but
then in fact there was an incentive for
them not to want him correct
but this this is this there is real
incentive there
they want us to buy their oil and we and
we did the moment trump gets out we go
from being an exporter to uh importer
that's right yeah we were energy
independent and we should be energy
dominant we should be the number one
look you all are way too young to
remember i was around in 1973
when the uh when the saudis taught us
about oil embargoes yep and you talked
about some of your talks earlier about
somebody wants to re re-live or bring
back the oil export ban and we're saying
look that means jobs
i actually voted for that in 2015
in december 2015 got beat up for a
little bit but we want to be sure we
export bans russia disinformation it was
happening in the campaign earlier we all
know that it's just the democrats
had brought that out
listen what they took to the fiasco
court some of those activists and the
fbi my sons and fbi as i said earlier
most of them almost all of them great
but there was a few activists at the top
of the chain there in the fbi what they
did by lying to a federal court the fisa
court if you and i brought information
to any kind of court and cert and signed
off that it was right they knew it
wasn't right we would be under the
jailhouse so that russia collusion is
kind of stuck in people's craw for a
long time but when we discovered this in
2017 lamar smith and i wrote a letter
right then to uh steve mnuchin secretary
of the treasury and said look there's
some money laundering going on here you
need to check into it and there's a lot
of facts that show uh shale companies in
bermuda that have been moving money over
into sierra club for example sea change
there's a whole bunch of clubs that get
them i could go on the list i've got a
list here in my notes
and they literally are funding some of
the stuff going on over there that's a
fact you can't deny it and look at this
look at this photo the town hall has
look at that smile as joe biden shakes
the hand of vladimir putin well that
proves it that proves they're colluding
oh no this is what they did so much of
with trump absolutely i just i showed
trump next to putin oh yeah yeah like
biden just looks like
smiling like an idiot
this looks really
really actually
[Laughter]
there was that one video of trump
shaking putin's hand and like pulling
him in yeah oh he does that yeah he does
he would he would shake their hand and
then pull everybody yeah like assert
your dominance this that's not what's
happening there who was who was the one
person i think trudeau
like pushed his leg out and then didn't
let trump do it and then all the left
was like yeah go trudeau and they were
cheering or whatever yeah i'm wondering
what they're thinking about him today
yeah
well the same truckers think they they
still keep defending people like that so
so i think it's fair to point out as we
previously mentioned putin has a real
reason to incentivize the united states
to get off of fossil fuels so that we
become dependent upon them it's not hard
we also have uh natural gas in europe as
well has there been any indication that
they're doing similar practices in
europe oh absolutely the actual campaign
went against fossil fr fuels in in terms
of fracking in terms of lng
uh everything that they did in europe
and and they're doing over here now my
district as you know exports lng and
they look for 20-year contracts
and so when they contract with a country
like poland and some of the others it's
a long-term contract
putin is seeing that he doesn't want
that lng is a bit esoteric so just once
again for anyone who's liquefied
liquefied natural gas yeah well yeah
that's that's that's real quick that's
nordstrom too uh right there doing
liquefied natural gas from russia to
germany and the interesting thing is the
ceo of nordstream 2 is a friend of who
knew putin one of his confidants yep
right and even of gas prom one of the
top one of the top officials of gas prom
is a a friend of putin's i think they
have ties back to not the 90s when they
were together in the mayor's office
right oh i got it i got to i got to ask
you about um
joe biden and barisma
i mean you seem to be one of the experts
on energy if not the expert and so you
take a look at what's happening with uh
you know donald trump ukraine gate
barisma hunter buying another laptop
story yeah my my my view of this because
i've been i've been following these
stories for you know almost a decade
with the qatar turkey pipeline syria
assad and of course the u.s trying to i
should say the west wanting to offset
russia's control of natural gas through
ukraine you got gas coming through
israel you could come up to cyprus and
yeah there's a lot of discussion about
that too so uh
what what's the religion is there
something going on was there something
going on with the u.s barisma in
attempting to shut down russia's you
know control with you know that's one
thing i'm not familiar with i started
hearing first hearing about that with
with the biden thing when literally joe
biden hunter biden and by the way i know
they're concerned because with ukraine
and a heck of a mess it is now i mean
does that mean hunter biden's salaries
getting cut
but any investigation about that was
shut down his check bounce right like
well
well and look joe biden you know he did
this on a video he said you know what i
told him that if they didn't fire this
guy that was investigating that company
he said they don't get the one billion
dollars right and sob
you know what do you know six hours
later he was fired if it really does
feel uh uh to me like you know i i think
there's nato's interest in getting a
cheaper gas into europe and then i feel
like biden was uh looking to wet his
whistle he thought hey look here's my
opportunity we're gonna it's in the u.s
interest to do this but i'm gonna make
some money off it germany's really
intertwined in all this too they have
this like rose of luxembourg foundation
and they are affiliated with democratic
socialists and they have an office in
new york um and they hold these training
sessions on how to like protest
pipelines and fracking and the whole
nine yards and they they also do they
team up with um sea change and the
sierra club so then there's this guy ben
beachy who works for the sierra club
who's he meeting with on the hill lately
aoc jayapal all of them and then you go
to his social media he said every single
antifa protest everyone i wonder if aoc
you know is aware
of what the ramifications of her
advocacy would mean
i i like to shout out greta tunberg you
know everyone's you know how dare you um
because i stole him she has that quote
where she said we don't want to wait
until 2030 or 2023 we want to end fossil
fuels now
how many people would you estimate will
die
overnight if we immediately just shut
off fossil fuels 60 million oh my gosh
you know just think of the just think of
the cold winter's up north uh and you
know new york doesn't by the way the
state of new york doesn't buy lng from
america they buy from russia wow we we
they do we call it the dirty putin yes
wait wait wait so so now that we've
banned imports from russia new york is
in trouble that you would sure hope so
you betcha
well you can't trust the buying
administration they may have carved out
an exception you know what i mean but
think about it
and not only that but we generate
electricity with it in the south so
people could die from no air
conditioning in the south in the
summertime when it's 100 degrees
diabetics instantly because your insulin
is going to be refrigerated
people can't drive to work food spoils
absolutely hospitals oh yeah and those
who are on
dialysis machines
i don't think the squad gets it and my
wife i told my wife that we ought to
call them the odd squad and she said
don't tell people that
i love it so you just did
so if you want to see that it's randy he
always does what he's not supposed to do
i'm not supposed to say they're the ones
what i'm saying yeah but i i really do
wonder if uh
i i i'm of the opinion that
ocasio-cortez absolutely knows people
will die
and she doesn't care i genuinely because
these are these are not the kind of
people that would come on a show like
this and actually have a sit down
conversation about those things she's
not the kind of person i mean look when
she told the story on january 6
when she told the story of january 6 she
completely fabricated it and just i i
have to tell everybody every time this
comes this comes up but she said there's
a knock on her door and
then she went in the bathroom and she
heard someone say where is she yeah and
she she thought to herself
they made it in the issue was that
incident happened an hour before anyone
breached the capitol building so the
office is in our building just so you
know so
her office is in our building i don't
know for sure and it didn't happen at
all but what happened was when
conservatives pointed that out the media
said yes but there are tunnels so aoc
being scared was reasonable and i said
no it wasn't because her story happened
a full hour before anyone even knew the
building was going to be breached yeah
which means if there's no possible way
she was in her office thinking to
herself they made it here she made that
up and she was colluding with those who
were born absolutely the only tunnel
they could have gotten through through
the capital would be the cannon tunnel
which was immediately the first thing
they shut down so not true so the whole
story is fabricated and when you hear
things like that i just assume
she
she makes things up
so it's possible that she doesn't know
what she's talking about when it comes
to climate and she's just saying
whatever she needs to say that's why i
believe but it's also possible she's
completely aware of what it would mean
to just shut off fossil fuels and do
what she's planning on doing i mean the
whole green new deal look when when the
green new deal was first being proposed
it was it was a bit vague it was this
idea of government investing in green
energy and i in my opinion i'm like that
sounds fantastic american energy
independence the renewable doesn't say
we're not talking about getting rid of
fossil fuels we're talking about
bolstering our technology maybe even
fusion power what did we get the bill
was social justice free college free
health care and get rid of farting cows
well she's the boss tim
remember that no one else is proposing
ideas i'm the boss right oh right right
but you know what she did that was smart
that like republicans i don't seem to
always do is that she messaged it and
messaged it and messaged it when she was
she had no power she was a freshman in
congress right right she got it in the
minds of every single person out there
through the young people and all and
then now they had to do something with
it so it has evolved over time and
that's why organizations like rosa
luxemburg foundation and these people
that are doing this propaganda are
latching onto that and filling it
filling that with
terrible substance because she doesn't
have it on her own i i just want to say
i feel like if you took the average
american who votes a democrat and just
sat them down with say you randy and aoc
they'd be voting republican after half
an hour or they'd be calling him racist
enough no i no i don't think so you
don't think so there are there are
they're right there are culti people who
just want to fit in i'm talking about
your regular working class person who
says i need to feed my kids
conversations like this we don't see
them these people don't come on the show
they we've invited many people on the
left it's hard to get what we end up
getting is mock offers from leftist
personalities who want to just troll us
sometimes we do have more left-leaning
personalities who are willing to come on
the show and they'll argue with us but
for the most part
it's a very serious concern greta
tunberg said shut down fossil fuels
right now that would result in 60
million or so dead
what's your proposal you never get an
answer to those questions because
they're not willing to answer them on
these shows i don't think they're
genuine people which is why i say you
take a regular person you take aoc you
take randy you put them in a room and
they're gonna walk out and be like i
didn't get any answers from the left
yeah i mean you're right from the
perspective of these left-wing activists
they have no reason to justify any of
their positions they're just correct as
was summarized by aoc when she said
people will criticize you for being
factually inaccurate when you're morally
correct oh yeah that was great
yeah so are you saying when you say the
lefties won't come on so chris cuomo
hasn't accepted your invitation
well i'm actually i would assume
first of all with chris cuomo he's he's
he's probably too big you know he
doesn't care he's getting paid millions
of dollars now he's doing a suit and
we're not fans of his he probably
wouldn't want to come on just because
you know we've been you know
very very like opposed to him
but um well and you're telling things
like it is right people ought to be did
i mention people ought to be sharing
this program
oh you know i'll give you i'll give you
a really good example um genkuger of the
young turks or anna casparian for
instance i understand they do the wrong
show it's a fair point to say they have
no time to come out here to the east
coast and come on our show when they do
their own show
however they have done they go out of
their way often to misrepresent our
views and lie about us just today the
daily beast wrote a fake story about uh
tulsi gabbard as well as me it was uh
jared holt who used to work for right
wing right wing watch he just wrote a
fabricated narrative falsely accusing us
of pushing a cue conspiracy about bio
labs in ukraine when all we did here on
the show was say wow victoria nuland
testified before the senate that she was
concerned about these biolabs and then
they try and make it seem like we're
pushing weird conspiracies about
vladimir putin stopping weapons or
something which we never did
and so when you so we've invited jared
holt on the show several times he won't
do it he won't come on the show and i
think it's because he knows
he will be absolutely eviscerated in
terms of the facts
yeah they're able to stand in their
ivory tower shouting down lies to the
chances they have no reason to come here
and be proven wrong and you know
victoria newlin was a holdover from
obama right oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah so she testified there's a ukraine
has bio labs and there's a fear that if
russia gets a hold of them you know
there could be problems
and that's what we said in fact what we
did say as well was we said uh the maps
showing
russian attacks and biolabs don't even
sync up
and yet the daily beast publishes a
story accusing uh tulsi gabbard me
tucker carlson of pushing lies
in line with the with with the kremlin
for simply citing victoria newland
these people won't come on and be proven
wrong which is why i say if you sat down
with them and and and here's the
fascinating thing too like you're
sitting here saying you know texas is
the is the win state it's what number
one you said right yes sir
that's great news to many of these
people on the left texas is doing a
fantastic job in terms of renewable but
you've got some honest points to make
you need year-round energy to be
available and wind can't can't be all of
that that's right
but they don't want to hear it and
they're and and we know that some of the
elements in in the wind energy system uh
especially if you're talking about
batteries and solar panels and stuff
they hate nuclear the left hates nuclear
because they don't want to know what to
do with the waste and they pretty much
they killed yucca mountain even though
that was a great design
and so wind energy has waste at some
point in time there's going to be
something that's got to be done
something with batteries are the same
way if you've ever had a car with a
battery it need to be replaced guess
what it's going to be done something
done with it and it's really difficult
to to deal with these large massive
electric car batteries yeah and it's and
it's also where do they think the
electricity comes from for these
electric cars the fascinating thing is
you know
i really wish these people would take
energy economics 101 the basic beginning
so they can undertake understand things
like energy return on energy invested
they can understand the root of all
energy and and the us and and human
economy i watch this really great
documentary and it starts off in you
know tribal caveman era and it said the
first form of energy utilized by man was
man's own energy using his own arms to
to uh run to hunt and then we started
using tools and leverage
then we started at some point lumber
burning wood and burning wood allowed us
to do things then we had coal then you
know we apply coal to say steam for from
motion develop the wheel in order to
move things right it was talking about
i'm sorry i skipped over animals so
humans use their own hands then they
started using basic tools for leverage
but then they used animal energy cows
could eat oxen could eat grass and then
pull something they couldn't pull
eventually they figured out to burn you
know carbon then eventually coal then
eventually we discovered petroleum which
was massively energy dense nuclear
energy and so we're constantly trying to
find ways to maximize energy output with
minimal energy input and that's energy
return on energy invested which
they don't understand any of these
concepts and especially the investment
part of it you know when you've got a
federal government that's so anti-fossil
fuel making it's so hard for people to
invest money and i don't care whether
it's a windmill farm whether it's a
nuclear facility whether it's a gas fire
power plant when you've got to jump
through all the hoops and all the
regulations and it takes two or three
years to plan something uh they're
making it hard to build energy and
you've got china out there depends on
whose numbers you're using
making a coal plant a week a month
whatever it is is uh i don't know if you
you know the answer but is nuclear has
the highest energy return on energy
invested is it nuclear might be
petroleum it's it's going to depend on
the market value at any given point
right
right yeah but i will tell you that for
nuclear to go and put in a nuclear
system and a facility and it's billions
of dollars yeah now so the payback is
going to stretch way out and when you're
an investor and you're looking at those
things and the federal government's
making it extremely hard for you on the
front end to even get a permit let's
just say in two years you go i don't
want to necessarily wait that long i
should probably uh
give an understanding of was it
e-r-o-e-i or whatever uh for people who
don't understand it's basically
fracking for a long time was what would
produce less energy than we would put
into it it was not worth producing it
the investment wouldn't come back out of
it and then once gas prices started to
become more higher and higher all of a
sudden we could put in the energy to get
energy back so what this means is
if you spend let's let's do it by hours
it's really easy way to understand it if
it takes you 100 hours to get a wind
turbine up but that wind turbine can
only produce 101 hours of energy it's a
very very weak return on building this
massive structure so you're using
petroleum energy to get back even one i
think a lot of these renewables actually
have a negative return so we're having
solar installed at uh at our new
facility and we're looking at i think
it's you know 30 or 40 years before we
generate enough energy to cover the
energy required to make the panels and
the batteries
so we use oil
to run the machines that make the solar
and the batteries and that system cannot
generate more energy than the oil that
was put into it it's it's convenient for
us that if the power goes out we will
have backup power it's convenient for us
that we can generate our own power on a
sunny day but it takes oil energy to
give us that convenience hopefully in
the future we're at a point where
we can use wind energy to charge
electric vehicles and factories to build
more wind energy but that's the big
challenge one of the big challenges we
face well think about all the stuff that
was built in that scenario you just laid
out if you're building up silting
they're bringing huge solar panels it's
going to be carried by a diesel truck
that uses diesel maybe we'll do cyber
truck
maybe we'll have the uh elon musk
delivered by cyber truck powered by
solar panels
but uh certainly we're decades away from
anything like that i'm just like that's
going to be before i'll be long gone by
then yeah right we're going to miss you
i do i do think
that the challenge is
that uh
just oil is so massively energy dense
which provides a great opportunity the
discovery and implementation of oil you
can see it in human population expansion
it was just massive well here's the
other thing too tim we have been good
and look fossil fuel in and of itself is
not the enemy
we can produce energy cleanly from
fossil fuel
in fact i was on the environmental red
community in the state of texas i
mentioned earlier and we oversaw a lot
of the emissions in texas you know we
have our own facility
uh tcerq text commercial environmental
equality in texas it's the second
largest environmental regulatory agency
in the country second on to the epa
and we do a good job of monitoring our
things in texas we were reducing
emissions when you've got when we kill
our if the left gets their way and they
kill fossil fuel
i'm sure that when we kill our fossil
fuel industry then china's going to
follow suit india is going to follow
mexico is going to follow suit russia is
going to follow suit no
we can produce energy cleanly and china
doesn't produce energy as clean with you
as we do russia doesn't do it india
doesn't do it mexico doesn't do it
they're major polluters and so why are
we seeking to kill our energy industry
over here when it be less than i forget
what the figure is less than 1 100th of
a percent of all the emissions in in the
in the world
no
we need to be doing it as cleanly as we
can and it's national security it's
domestic security it's economic security
and it's family security quite frankly
because as you pointed out they've got
to be able to drive cars go to the
grocery store that's right thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you